sarahbk un magasin de cd de dvd dans la
vidéo club de voile elle a son petit
magasin de cd d'un dvd il ya un mec qui
rentre il dit excusez moi est-ce que
vous avez des films pornos et lui dit
oui on a des films pornos pour vaut pour
tous
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout ça allô allô oui oui bon
choix
oui je sais ça guérit dire que c'est un
[Applaudissements]
bébé je suis là j'ai comme les italiens
bonne à teahupoo série blake de suite
dans le sud de la france pareil tous
ensemble on était en train compte des
plaques dans le sud au thème hausse et
on espère qu'il viendra bientôt sur
platon cyr et je sais que toi hein tu
attends tous et on t'aime sport et drake
tu veux nous raconter un petit à petit
buy way they les loups les lots ils
arrivent avec des parents dans les
années 60 il arrive de tunis et parle
très bien chanté mellel où il habite
dans il parle pas du falga étals sous
les sons pertes et par mois là on arrive
en france mêlant la loge ponctue par les
tuvalu veut pas le leur il pleure et
vous bref ils l'emmènent unité coûte les
loups maintenant on est en france il
faut absolument je vais t'emmener chez
les bonnes soeurs et ont même chez les
bonnes soeurs là-bas dans une campagne
il tape à la porte ce qui par
bref s'ils rentrent et il ya une bonne
sortie du rapport il est diplomate à
olaya monfils la louche que vaut le
laisser pendant six mois s'il vous plaît
il aimerait vraiment je suis sûr que ça
va lui plaire et quand je reviens donc
moi voilà je suis sûr qu'avec vous il va
apprendre le français mais bien sûr
monsieur avec toutes les îles
elle est en relais lugo compreniez entre
la louyre ans à six mois après son père
ils arrivent ils tapent à la porte
il vient rechercher son fils il est très
heureux comme pai s'apparente y retrouve
sur la même bonne soeur bonjour madame
si messi me rappelle très bien de vous
vous êtes le papa de laine ou lydie oui
bien sûr élève la voix la sortante
à plélo lalo au tac à la blague et je
suis un vrai bilan de ces matches est
fort mon frérot merci d'abord j'espère
toi t'as du boulot c'est un arabe oui on
change pas c'est un arabe en fait qui a
un problème avec ses dents fait hyper
hyper ses dents et il lui reste que
dedans donc il va chez le dentiste est
déjà un problème chez permet dans les
météores il faut me mettre des dents
mais témoin des dents dans this is back
il lui dit bart nous on a les incisives
c'est 10 euros
les fans insee 50 euros et les molaires
ses 100 euros l'arabie l'organe du
frérot mais moi des incisives partout
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]